calling for in is something that you're
not allowed to do in the UK call for
murder you're not allow you're not
allowed to let me finish one other case
Douglas Mar went on peers Morgan last
night they got into it about uh Free
Speech relative to these protests we've
been at the center of allowing these
people to be in our country and indeed
to plot Terror from our country for
years so it's always a bit Rich to hear
the British I think uh lecturing others
about being an unsound part of of the
International Security uh community as
for the actual marches look um I'm
afraid that the rules on this are very
very clear um you are not allowed to
glorify Terror or call for Terror on the
streets of Britain and that existed
before the 2006 terrorism act banned
glorification and it certainly exists
now uh if you stand on the Streets of
London Calling for Jihad you are calling
for Terror and that is actually a place
where free speech is at its limit and is
no longer permissible it's the same with
for instance calls for in on the London
tubes remember we had a touch of in on
the London tubes a few years ago so
again calling for in is something that
you're not allowed to do in the UK call
for murder you're not allow you're not
allowed to let me finish one other case
you're not allowed uh to stand on the
Streets of London and call for the
murder of Jews or any other minority and
yet people have been getting away with
this satday after satday and and and are
the police arresting people no no
they're not the police last week said
we're outnumbered all right again we
could have played you the full clip
until a lot of butts and pauses from
peers that he wants to appear objective
I'm not bashing peers again I've been on
the show sure he's not a horrible human
being but this this thing where they do
this moral equivalence do you want to
live in a society and this is what
Liberals are now going to have to figure
out liberals who are generally the old
school liberal tradition the ACLU
allowing neo-nazis to march in skoki
Illinois in
1972 uh to express their freedom of
speech and that's what that was the
liberal position back then but that is
fundamentally different from where we
are at now where hundreds of thousands
of people are out on the street who have
been misinformed and and their the
education system and the cultural
attache has completely failed them so
that they think Up Is Down and good guys
are bad guys and they're celebrating
this medieval barbarism and all of that
stuff when they start calling for Jihad
that is calling for violence when you
say River to the Sea it is calling for
genocide when you target Jewish
businesses or you go to specifically
places where you know Jews or Israelis
are what should a liberal Society do at
that point we that is the precarious
spot that we are at right
now